TIMOTHY JORDAN: Menu items.
When you insert a timeline card
for the user, you can
also add menu items.
Now, these menu items can be
system actions such as reply
or read aloud, and they can also
be custom, which can be
whatever you want.
You get to name them and
choose what they do.
Now, it looks a little
bit like this encode.
When you do an insert post
request for the timeline card,
you'll include your text,
your HTML, or whatever.
And then you'll also add
these menu items.
Now, what I have here
is a system menu
item for read aloud.
All you've got to do is name it,
and that item is going to
show up on the user's
timeline.
And when they tap on that
option, they'll get the text
read aloud to them.
If you want to do a custom menu
item, you have to add a
little bit more information.
In this case, I've got a custom
menu item for love.
I've included a display name
of love, and I've also
included an icon URL.
Now, when the user sees this
menu item, they're going to
tap on it, of course, because
who doesn't love love?
And then you're going to get a
notification saying that the
user has selected
this menu item.